[Music]
now quick question are you looking to
get transported to italy in literally 10
minutes from now because i'm going to
show you how you can eat like a normal
italian with some incredible greens but
more importantly delicious cheese with a
sumptuous polenta right oscar pan down
first vegetable stock okay that's going
to be brought up to the boil after that
we got a beautiful polenta now this is a
quick fire plate okay takes about four
and a half minutes to cook
super fine grain maize okay delicious
over here we've got some beautiful
frozen spinach
fresh broccolini asparagus super snack
peas wild garlic a little bit of lemon a
nice firm tart goat's cheese bit of
mascarpone butter salt pepper and a
touch of olive oil
to sort of enrich that planter
right let's have 10 minutes on the clock
okay first things first get your
vegetable stock and bring it up to the
ball turn your steamer on
and leave that getting nice and hot
before you season a stock
taste it okay
so that just takes off a really nice
sort of deep
aromatic vegetable stock bring it up to
the ball give a little touch
of salt give it a touch
of chili flakes
give a little touch of fresh pepper i
like to
sit a little bit of extra virgin olive
oil on top of my
stock in order to make it a little bit
more richer let's come to the boil
turn the gas down
and literally just shake
and stir
shake
and stir
now this is a quick fire polenta okay so
it gets very thick
very quickly
now
the secret
is to make it rich
creamy
and incredibly moorish
look at that beautiful again
if you just clump it all in there like
that it's going to go a little bit lumpy
so take your time
sort of making great polentas like
making a risotto give it love give it
attention and more importantly look
after it
right plenty in
now from there turn the gas down
and this is where we're going to start
lifting
the incredible flavor of that polenta
the whisk has done its job
in goes my spoon as it comes that nice
soft ball you can see it sort of almost
a little bit like oatmeal or porridge
it's starting to go a little bit sort of
you know bubbly turn the gas down
continue stirring
and now
we're gonna lift it up
again we're gonna enhance it
garlic is something that goes very well
in polenta
okay but we're gonna fry it microplane
and just grate that garlic
well
that gets it almost pureed quickly and
from there
you can see now underneath all that
beautiful garlic in there so just tap
hit it with the back of the spoon
get all that garlic in there
beautiful now on this really cool
[Music]
light
hint of garlic
it's bubbling it's starting to thicken
as well still not cooked yet it's been
on there for 90 seconds the spinach
really important that
you just literally get the spinach in
your hand
and just squeeze out
any excess water
and then literally
bunch it up chop it
and go through just go through it once
and again
you can use fresh spinach if you want it
just turns the planter a little bit more
watery i like the frozen spillage
squeezed out and now
put it in in two goes half in
and there you go now
take that off the heat
and start mixing that up
so
i want that to sit there for a little
bit
okay
whilst
the spinach sort of opens up it changes
color the plenty goes a little bit
darker a little bit richer and look i
want to sort of
let that hang off
spoon
glaze the polenta that touch more
olive oil let it sit there
and i'll come back to that in a minute
now vegetables
with this i like the healthy idea of
steaming the vegetables i've got some
fresh asparagus that's broccoli nielsen
sugar snap peas
over
they go lightly season them bunch them
up i want a bit of a crunch
a little bit of a drizzle on there
these little baskets are brilliant
for steaming vegetables touch of pepper
and even though we're steaming them we
can enhance the flavor just a little
touch of olive oil on there lid on
they're going to take about four four
and a half minutes
now
the polenta
how do i get that sort of revved up how
do i get it into a different league
lemon zest first juice goes in at the
end
when i add that olive oil it sort of
slows it down to a nice rich creamy
texture
but
it needs more richness
so now
i start adding in
my butter
and i put sort of nice little slices of
butter in get it back on the heat
and then we start beating that butter in
that's so good so so good don't let it
sit there
get it in
and literally
whip it in
you'll see why in a minute
the heat is on low
the butter's melting nicely
okay and
it's working it's magic
and all you're doing
is making sure that you've got this
lovely
creamy texture
now for some more green
frozen peas
get them in
okay straight from the freezer get them
in
and then once i've got that nice
consistency the heat of the planter will
cook the peas
okay
it's starting to sort of cook fully
it's smelling delicious
mascarpone cream cheese
that's the winner for me
that's the one that literally takes
the polenta to a nice rich
and delicious planter
lemon juice
halfway
lemon juice in
and give that a really good squeeze
now
back onto the heat
whack the heat up
i'm cooling it down with the mascarpone
cheese
i've got the lemon juice in there now my
peas are working they're magic the
spinach and the peas go beautifully
together and now look
now that polenta
is coming together
and that's why this dish is so
lovely
and so creamy
it's just a really nice
light
way of eating polenta
cheese
in at the end
and
this gives it a beautiful
added richness
i like a aged parmesan pecorino is
beautiful we sit goat cheese
on top
as it's done and look
back on
and now
look what's happened in the last five
minutes
this polenta
become like a royal planter look at that
beautiful
quick taste
time please
touch more salt
and this has just come into season
and it's like the wild garlic leaves
i roll that up like a big beautiful
monte cristo cigar
slice it
not too fine
and that sort of freshness of that wild
garlic at the end
is beautiful
now
if your polenta's getting a little bit
too
sort of stiff
touch more stock
touch more mascarpone
i'm happy with mine
i just love the way it sits
on the plate
by that bridge
and beautiful now
gas off
when i come to plate it
i want to be generous
okay on she goes
scoop that on there
it's got an amazing flavor
whatever you don't use on the day
set this in the fridge
for the next day and it turns out
this beautiful fried polenta cake when
you crisp it up in the frying pan let
that sit
vegetables are off
and then lock
shake that there
and then
finally olive oil on top
a touch of seasoning on top
and then
goat's cheese just
sit down
on there
that starts the melt
time please
and then finally
this goat cheese will melt beautifully
and make the polenta even richer
good wash the hands
now
for your beautiful vegetables look at
those
they are
beautiful
really beautiful
so
they're cooked
in lemon we've got a little touch
of bite
and they're fresh
and we could sew to these vegetables but
having these steamed in amongst the
richness of that polenta
is beautiful i love it and it's so
healthy
good
time please
and then literally
on
finally
my lemon
a touch of my aged
para masala
and then
come on
these beauties here it's just mint
fresh mint drop it on there fresh mint
goat's cheese delicious polenta all done
in under 10.
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsay and
ten cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're gonna come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck